[Musique]
sur le tracé qui viennent mba paix est
un champion sur le terrain des affaires
le jeune prodige de 21 ans semble là
aussi faire des miracles avec son seul
salaire de footballeur au psg le jeune
homme ans fauchée chaque année la
coquette somme de 20 millions d'euros un
total auxquels il faut ajouter une prime
négociée en cas de victoire du ballon
d'or qui s'élève à 1,1 million d'euros
et dans le monde du sport le salaire ne
fait pas tout selon le magazine capital
avec ces deux contrats exclusives avec
l'équipementier sportif nike et la
marque de montres de luxe hublot
la star de paris s'offre une petite
rallonge de plus de 4 millions d'euros
par an sans compter que nike a lancé
plusieurs produits dérivés à son image
par exemple la collection bondi dreams
dont la paire de crampons et vendu 290
euros à noter que kilian m bape et
touchant plus 10 à 15% des royalties de
ses produits dérivés et côté produits
dérivés qui gagnent ne s'arrête pas là
il possède également son propre site
internet sur lequel les casquettes à 35
euros et les photos dédicacées à 250
euros s'arrache cette activité annexe
lui rapporterait 1,2 million d'euros
chaque année
et comme tous les grands kilian est
aussi un homme de coeur l'an dernier il
aurait reversé 350000 euros à
l'association premier de cordée qui
propose des initiations sportives pour
les enfants hospitalisés il n'y a pas à
dire quand on nous dit que rien ne sert
de courir qui viennent nous prouve le
contraire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans capital vraiment vraiment très très
bien faite par françois amigues échec
dans quel cadre du magazine capital
merci d'être avec nous françois rey
c'est moi qui vous remercie alors
franchement on apprend des choses
incroyables moi qui suis fan de
quillanais mbappé alors info qui en amap
et gagne environ 30 millions d'euros par
an sa valeur de transfert est estimé à
300 millions d'euros minimum
c'est un record pour gérer ce business
qui a même appelé on apprend qu'il est
essentiellement avec son père un oui en
fait il n'est pas avec son père il ya un
clan il est avec son père sa mère
d'accord mais avec son avocate qui
l'appelle delphine verheyden qui est un
avocat spécialisé dans le sport avec une
vraie terreur a well as du barreau en la
matière celle distincte des autres
joueurs qui en général ont des entrées
en des entourages bien plus est avec des
agents il paraît qu'elle a quand même
une quinzaine de collaborateurs ce que
vous dites dédié quand même à lui
oui c'est ça alors dans le cabinet de
l'avocate delphine vers aden ya un
certain nombre de collaborateurs j'avais
une quinzaine en effet qui sucre avec
tous les rails pour la pme mba paix mais
la paix msp c'est 30 millions d'euros
par an quand même 30 millions d'euros
environ
d'accord alors son périple qui c'est un
très bon négociateur ce que vous dites
sinon en passant de monaco à paris
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il y là il a
multiplié la rémunération par combien
bar 13,1
c'est ouais c'est pas moi qui l'ait
révélé c'est arnaud hermant de
l'exécuter avec biographie de killian m
bape et son père wilfrid mba pc1 un
grand sportif l'ancien entraîneur des
jeunes de de bondy et c'est quelqu'un
qui est aussi un fin négociateur dans le
monde
alors pour vous êtes intéressé au cas
mba paix et parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une des plus
grandes stars on sait la plus grande
star française on va pas se mentir
ben oui alors c'est vrai qu'à capitale
on n'a pas l'habitude de faire des
portraits de grands sports c'est ça
ouais sauf cas exceptionnel on l'avait
fait pour neymar et on l'avait fait pour
rodger federer
d'habitude cette rubrique elle est
plutôt consacré à des chefs d'entreprise
des premiers ministres d'accord et on le
fait quand ils ont une dimension
exceptionnelle et c'est vraiment le cas
de kylie ann m bat p alors est ce qui
aujourd'hui vous dites qu'il est autant
businessman que footballeur alors il est
plus footballeur encore un petit peu que
business man mais il va il a un
potentiel absolument énorme star qui
gagnent environ
donc 30 millions d'euros par an à
seulement 21 ans ça c'est juste son
contrat de foot parce qu'il a des
sponsors d'alors le montra de foot c'est
environ 20 22 millions d'euros par an
voilà le reste c'est 30 millions en tout
ouais en tout c'est environ 30 millions
ce qui fait quand même 80 mille euros
par jour très bien d'accord alors si par
action et 2000 c'est bon l'anc est aussi
et ça ça intéresse étaient les
spectateurs que son père et sa mère
leurs cadres régulièrement
oui alors ça c'est ce qu'on a découverte
est assez amusant c'est que ses parents
ne veulent surtout pas que kilian m bape
et prennent trop la grosse tête ce
qu'ils veulent c'est qu'il garde bien
les pieds sur terre et sa mère qui a un
fort caractère qui s'appelle faïza al
amari hésite pas leurs cadres et même
parfois devant témoins et donc elle dit
arrête qui viennent de elle lui dit pas
prendre la grosse tête mais surtout elle
dit monfils a peint avec inventé le
vaccin contre la rage
elle a dit mon fils n'est pas l'abbé
pierre arrêtez de vous exciter on voit
la lcl lui évite de prendre la grosse
tête
voilà elle s'étonne que les journalistes
parfois aussi ils agissent un peu comme
des courtisans et donc elle les remet un
peu sur le salaire andrée on attendait
mon fils s'est pas non plus alors il
paraît que sa communication et ses
apparitions sont comparables à celles
d'emmanuel mâcon il paraît que c'est
vraiment c'est alors c'est très calculé
c'est pas moi qui le dit une certaine
manière c'est jacques séguéla que j'ai
interviewés donc grand publicitaire je
suis reconnaissez pour pour cet article
qui dit que la stratégie de
communication de quillan et maps et
c'est une stratégie présidentielle part
ça il entend c'est une stratégie de
parole rare un peu comme françois
mitterrand en son temps qui était
conseillé par jacques pilhan et ce
qu'ils essayent de faire mâcon mais
emmanuel macron fait pas forcément aussi
bien qu'il ya même eu d'accord mais
alors oui peut-être que klm pape est
allé au salon de l'agriculture lma quoi
est ce que qu'il ya des maps et c'est un
fêtard comme neymar ou ou pas du tout
alors justement quand on enquête bien on
se rend compte que pas trop non ça joue
à la [ __ ] appelé 1 il joue en effet à
la playstation
il est fan de nba tout cas il paraît
non alors il est on le voit il est sorti
au loto est sorti ou matignon dans les
clubs où on voit neymar et verra tim
curry c'est le premier à rentrer chez
lui on le voit jamais avec un verre
d'alcool et pour l'anniversaire de
neymar par exemple il n'est pas resté
pour la photo finale ils étaient déjà
rentrés
c'est celui qui parle plutôt de paris il
boit jamais un verre d'alcool
oui et ce qu'on m'a raconté martin
leprince qu'un de ses biographes m'a
raconté quand il était à monaco qu'ils
avaient gagné je crois que c'était le
championnat à ce moment là ils ont tous
fait une grosse soirée champagne et
killian mbp lui est parti juste après le
dîner et la pas bu une goutte il allait
se coucher
alors il paraît qu'il a manqué aussi un
business autour de ces autographes c'est
quoi cette affaire alors c'est pas
vraiment un business source ces
autographes mais qu'il est même map et
il a monté une marque s'appelle cas m
il a un shop sur son site voila officiel
et sur lequel ils vendent des casquettes
35 euros des photos à 85 euros
et au moment où j'écrivais cet article
visiblement elles sont au sol date mais
elle était à 50 euros
il ya là où les 235 euros c'étaient les
photos dédicacées salaire si cher les
gens sont à chier choqué par sa folie
ils disent que ça c'est ça c'est
choquant parce que le chiffre d'affaires
ont brillé fils et deux à bergues domino
oui alors j'ai réussi à me procurer donc
les comptes de l'entreprise qui
chapeaute cette activité une entreprise
en fait qui porte les initiales de tous
les membres de la famille mba paix et
donc en 2018 de mémoire c'était environ
1,2 million d'euros de bénéfices quoi ça
sorte que la station avant goût
évidemment choqués hong kong gagne moi
je suis très content qu'il gagne
beaucoup d'argent qui gagne il est un
grand un grand sportif qui bien qu'ils
fassent des contrats publicitaires tout
ça est normal mais qu'on s'inspire les
fans 150 euros des photos dédicacées ou
s'il faut payer si j'avais su alors je
vous dirais croyez quoi surprendre la
défense de kilian qui viennent il faut
savoir qu'il à reverser sa prime de
champion du monde
c'est lui que direct à l'association
premier de cordée qui propose des
initiatives sportives pour les enfants
hospitalisés et finance aussi des
bourses pour près d'une centaine de
jeunes qui gagnent donc ça ça aussi mine
de rien qui n est pas plus important
aussi pour lui d'être dans l'associatif
d'aider des jeunes et d'aider d'autres
personnes c'est vrai en plus c'est la
surface de l'iceberg et mais revoilà
émerger
il ya aussi ces petits gestes qui fait
sans forcément avoir de micros de
caméras avec lui notamment il a remplacé
les véhicules de la seconde il récemment
des véhicules pour transporter les
joueurs
il a pas mal d'initiatives aux donateurs
pour l'association du psg j'étais avec
lui et dernière la soirée et c'est vrai
que sur les sur les enchères il y va
viva il y va il y va fort kilian oui ils
reversent effectivement l'argent des
autographes pour plein d'associations a
bondi c'est une icône main sur eux il
est pour la réhabilitation où il vient
jamais il a oublié et sa grande force
vous avez raison c'est sa famille parce
qu'à plein de footballeurs qui sont
pliés ou qui ont des problèmes avec leur
agent lui l'atout mais sous le cercle
familial et il sera un jour le record
mac du monde des transferts ou si j'ai
300 millions mais ça restera en famille
aurait pas de commission délirante à
désirer ça